this is a public trust in the government
from 58 to 2022 and if you look at that
from Eisenhower Kennedy say flat a
little bit higher and Eisenhower you
know warned about military industrial
complex Kennedy comes in they definitely
don't like the Kennedys for what they
have going on and then boom he's out
then Johnson comes in he loves power and
control so that goes down Nixon comes in
trust goes down obviously Watergate all
of that Ford comes in flat Carter comes
in down Reagan comes in he increases the
trust in the government during that
eight year Bush comes in goes down
Clinton comes and increases Bush comes
in down Obama comes in Flat Line Trump
comes and he increases it now Biden's in
here and you don't have the 2022 this is
uh the number I gave you was once
showing how dramatically it's dropped
the last three years uh the other one
that we were looking at which kind of
shows a completely different perspective
so
when you see this you know the closest
uh of institution that I can see as a
case study to the FBI is the mob and in
the mob there's something called omerta
omerta is when you uh you never share
what's going on on the inside you
essentially don't whistleblow in the mop
and if you do XYZ they're gonna come
after you and all this stuff right so
there's a threat of never one of the
code of honors of importance is not
coming out of Silence in the face of
questioning by authorities or Outsiders
and non-cooperation with authorities the
government or outside especially during
criminal investigations and willfully
ignoring and generally avoiding
interference with it I mean this sounds
like Hillary Clinton when she was being
held you know when she would not answer
anything yeah no no I play no no no no
no no no no right and when comey's going
through all this stuff 33 000 emails
what's the big deal yeah what's the
what's the big deal you delete emails
all the time what is the difference
between she broke her computer maybe she
was pissed off at Bill what does that
have to do with you anyways they were
talking about yoga pants right obviously
that's what the emails were all about
she wiped it with a rag yeah yeah
sweetheart right yeah but but here's the
part is there an omerto model in the FBI
where hey guys whatever we're doing
there's one thing you can ever do as an
FBI agent you can never whistle blow and
then behind closed doors you're being
trashed to say you guys can never trust
them because they whistle if you talk to
them just as soon as they're recording
the conversation just assume they're
going to say this is there that kind of
a Vibe and and energy in the FBI as well
or no
tell them about the training the new
training yes there is that Vibe for sure
and you got to tell them about your ASAC
and what he said to you but every year
every federal employee has to have it's
mandatory by government uh whistleblower
training every single year and Insider
threat training every single year
and my whole time in in the FBI they
were always separate this year we found
out because thankfully there are still
some good people in the FBI uh that that
training was merged into one so the FBI
didn't even they didn't even say you
know whistleblowing is good and you can
do it like they used to they used to say
yeah it's protected uh now they combine
those trainings overtly saying
whistleblowers are Insider threats I
mean that was the takeaway from the
people we know in the agency who took
that training that slide deck was
released to the public so we can go see
it it's online and it's like okay so the
FBI is not even trying to hide the fact
that they will retaliate against you and
I think that's government-wide look
what's happening with the IRS
whistleblower in his Squad right now but
the FBI has a culture they have had a
culture since Hoover's era of FBI first
no matter what and if you go against the
FBI I can see them we're coming for you
well I applaud you guys for
speaking truth to power right you're
shining light on Justice there's a lot
of people that probably do not want you
talking whatsoever who would you say is
at the top of that list what names what
people what institutions are like
Garrett friend get these guys silence
these guys muzzle them right now who's
at the top of that list I think the DNC
as a whole we we were you know in-person
recipients of that uh at that hearing
the things they were saying the way they
were twisting things and lying about us
and about our whistleblower status and
comparing us to people who committed
Espionage and whatever else and then uh
I think the mainstream media as well
because they're lackeys of the political
Elite and the political Elite are
typically on the left and so my
deposition that I went to in February
really stands out for me because I was
led to believe just like I was with my
transfer I was led to believe in good
and I I accepted both in good faith that
everything was kosher so I go to my
deposition a couple weeks later I get a
call from my attorney and he says hey
buddy I got I got some bad news for you
I got a call from CNN and they have your
name and they have some information
about your deposition I was told don't
talk about this deposition unless it's
with a privileged party and so I left
that deposition thinking like I you know
hopefully they will investigate this and
I told them there to the Democrat
attorneys as well who sat in on the
deposition because that's what I agreed
to do
because it's not a partisan issue or it
should not be a partisan issue but we're
seeing that it clearly is it's a right
or wrong issue it's like bro you have a
soul you you want to just be a good
person you're a Christian and it's like
well I'm we talk about this many
podcasts evil right now I don't care
what anybody thinks out there evil is
winning so hard and it's embedded in our
government the governments of the world
and I feel like it's we need people like
you but their their power is so freaking
strong they've all they've all sold
their souls to the devil and the price
is not cheap bro they gotta hold up that
bargain who else would you put on the
list you get the DNC you get the
mainstream media obviously the FBI okay
yeah at the FBI as a whole the ray
certain bureaucrats every other agent
SES level yeah at least or HQ as a whole
most likely okay who would you say yeah
I would I would agree that the executive
levels and also at the Department of
Justice too
um and uh
it that even goes down to the the
management structure uh even the ASAC
level uh so assistant special agents in
charge that are still on the GS scale
because they are climbers don't ruin my
gig for me so
um I'll name check Colt markovsky and
Sean Ryan as the asacs who sat in the
office for me and when Colt Marcotte
when I said to him that I took an oath
to protect the Constitution and he
responded back to me you have a duty to
the FBI
that was just a watershed moment for me
I when I took my oath I tore that oath
in front of God and my family and people
who sat around me who I thought were my
friends how uncomfortable is it to
actually name names at this point I mean
I I wouldn't uh I wouldn't pee on him if
he was on fire
here's my question in both of you since
you guys you know were in the FBI uh do
you think because you guys have come out
you're doing this are they monitoring
you guys are they do you think is there
a possibility because you guys will know
of anybody are they doing what they
actually do for a living yes are they
tapping you guys on pound they monitor
are they making sure you guys don't go I
mean I don't know at the depths of how
how much I'm pretty sure you guys have
information but you think they're
watching you guys I I don't know for
sure but the day I got suspended I had a
very odd thing happened with my phone
while I was talking to an attorney and
it basically cut out and then I couldn't
get back in touch with him and I was
getting an automated message and and
once I did get back in touch with him
and this guy this attorney he's a
retired FBI agent as also and I said hey
uh I explained to him what happened and
he goes oh yeah they probably tapped the
phone who do you think is watching this
right now uh headquarters right security
division definitely is I know that for a
fact I did an interview with them and
they were very tongue-cheek about oh we
were big fans of that podcast you did I
was like I'm glad you gave him did you
give him a like okay um yeah guys quick
reminder uh like subscribe to Peabody
podcast leave a five-star review yeah
yeah going back to what you were saying
when I asked the question about uh the
omerta the code and they trained you
it's FBI Above This you said you know
you got to tell your story what was the
one story you you wanted to share that
was the the he said my my duty was to
the FBI and not not to the Constitution
do you have to clip about you know uh
where I believe believe it's
um I want to say which one is it where
it says they will destroy you they will
crush you and your family I think you
have the clip if you can play this clip
uh uh uh on yeah it's that one right
there
uh this is um
Karen is this this is you talking in
this one yeah that's you just played a
whole clip I want the whole thing we
have a 20 second one we'll play this one
all of the hardships you've gone through
if one of your really good friends your
former colleagues came to you and said I
have this thing that is being covered up
and I think the American people know to
no need to know about it
what advice would you give them
I'll tell them first to pray about it
long and hard
and I would tell them I could take it to
Congress for them
or I could put them in touch with
Congress
but I would advise them not to do it so
you would legitimately try to protect
one of your colleagues from doing what
you have done absolutely
and how do you think that solves being
able to shine light on corruption
weaponization any kind of Mis misconduct
that exists with the American people it
doesn't solve it but the FBI will crush
you this government will crush you
and your family
if you try to expose the truth about
things that they are doing that are
wrong and we are all examples of that I
mean that's pretty powerful I can't
think of a more sobering way to end a
hearing I feel back
so so you would tell them not to so now
if you go back
a year ago and you're having that
conversation with your wife whatever the
timeline is when you when you you
wouldn't have done what you've done
already
uh I'm not saying
if I had a crystal ball I don't know
because how do you sleep at night then
and you know I have four little girl
girls now back then we had three and I
had a conversation with my ASAC at one
point and he was trying to walk me off
the ledge a little bit and I think he
was
he was he was acting like me doing the
wrong thing so just toeing the line
um was caring for my family I think that
that's cowardice and in the Book of
Revelation it tells us that cowards will
be judged uh when when they sit before
the Lord and
how could I then as a man raise my
daughters to be women of integrity and
to do the right thing even when it's
hard if I wasn't willing to do it so I'm
not saying I wouldn't have done it but
uh you know the congressman asked me if
one of my really good friends came to me
with that information Not only would I
do what I answered for a friend I would
do it for somebody that I don't know in
the FBI if if they were were too
unwilling or too afraid to do it but
they knew that they had something that
needed to be brought forward
um
I made that I made my oath many times
twice in the Army once when I reenlisted
um as a police officer as an FBI agent I
meant it and I was willing to stand in
the breach I'm in the breach now so
bring it to me that I'm that's fine I'm
I'm okay with that and we will get it to
Congress or whistleblower attorneys or
wherever it needs to go uh because the
American people need to know this stuff
yeah there's no question about it that
we need to know this stuff but you know
it ruins lives meaning people like you
it ruins your life and you know Sylvia
Garcia I think was a congresswoman from
California was trying to say you're not
a whistleblower you're not a
whistleblower you're not a whistleblower
I think Debbie Wasserman who comes
across as a total sweetheart from
Florida very good haired you know she
was talking about how this whole thing
is about the book and you're doing you
know just the book and then another lady
comes out and says you know I cannot
believe what you guys are doing this is
defunding the police on steroids she was
the one from U.S Virgin Islands
yeah when she said that so you you see
this stuff obviously this is the part of
discrediting right defund which was
phase one we're suspending you with pay
right if they're suspending you you're
not getting paid no no and in 7 500
which by the way strategically it's the
dumbest thing to do if you want somebody
to go away and not typically what would
happen in businesses here's a severance
package sign this definition Nation hold
harmless and move on they do the
opposite so these guys will be terrible
in business they're dummies if they're
not doing this the way to do this listen
we're going to give you one year this
good luck to you we're sorry it didn't
work out we'll see nothing but the best
but no they cornered you well you have
to do this and come out and talk about
it so also you know running an
organization is not a
wise thing that they're doing so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]